تستخدم روسيا في هجومها على اوكرانيا جزءا
من جيلها الجديد من الصواريخ التي تعتبرها
موسكو لا تقهر صاروخ كنجال البالستي او
الخنجر باللغه الروسيه احد صواريخ الجيل
الجديد من الاسلحه وهو قادر على الطيران
بعشره اضعاف سرعه الصوت يعتبر هذا الصاروخ
من احدث الاسلحه التي طورتها روسيا ضمن
الصواريخ الباليسيه التي تطلق من الجو
تقول موسكو ان هذا الطراز من الصواريخ
يمكن التحكم به بشكل كبير وتعجز عن رصده
كل انظمه الدفاع الجوي تبلغ سرعه هذا
الصاروخ نحو 12 الف كيلو متر في الساعه
وهو قادر على تدمير الاهداف بمدن يصل الى
2000 كيلو متر ويمكن تسليحه براس حربي
نووي الصاروخ مصمم ليطلق من على متن
طائرات مقاتله منها ميغ واحد وثلا ثون
وقاذفات تبوليف اثنان وعشرون ويبلغ وزن
راسه الحربي 500 كيلو جرام كما انه مخصص
لتدمير الاهداف المهمه للعدو وكذلك
باستهداف السفن الحربيه وحتى حاملات
الطائرات